you there will be failures they will need to be reported how are you going to deal with that welcome to adsp the podcast episode 193 recorded on july 11th 2024 my name is connor and today with my co-host bryce we chat with Kevlin Henney about Kevlin Henney's. So, switching topics a little bit, but one thing we haven't talked about is I've realized the original way that I know of Mr. Kevlin Henney is not from his talks or not from his books, but it's from the term kevlin henny which i can tell from the look of his face is something that he is well known for but perhaps not the thing that he would like to be remembered for but but can you explain what a kevlin henny is yeah i think i'm going to be remembered for it because you know it's uh yeah my name is now associated with failure yeah um literally so um back in the day um i started taking screenshots of you know if an application started crashing
总会有故障发生，这些故障需要被报告，你打算如何处理？欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 193 期，录制于 2024 年 7 月 11 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 将与 Kevlin Henney 聊聊 Kevlin Henney 的事。那么，稍微转换一下话题，有一件事我们还没聊过，我意识到我认识 Kevlin Henney 先生的原始方式并不是通过他的演讲或书籍，而是通过“Kevlin Henney”这个术语。从他的表情可以看出，这是他非常出名的一件事，但可能并不是他希望被人们记住的事情。你能解释一下什么是“Kevlin Henney”吗？是的，我想我会因此被记住，因为你知道，我的名字现在与失败联系在一起了。字面上就是这样。很久以前，我开始对应用程序崩溃的情况进行截图。
i'd take a screenshot of it you know it's just like oh okay let's say and i'd sometimes integrate it into a talk uh and then mobile phones with cameras, that was a thing. And it's just like, oh, okay, I can start taking, you know, we've got software everywhere in the world. But, you know, it's not all perfect. And we see a number of failures. And sometimes it's the software you write, sometimes it's something else about the system. But from the public's point of view, it's computer, it's failing, that's it. And I took pictures of these. I would include them in my talks. I'd include my workshops.
我会截屏，就像是“哦，好吧，就这样”。有时我会把它整合到演讲中。后来有了带摄像头的手机，这成了一种现象。就像是“哦，好吧，我可以开始记录了”。我们世界各地到处都是软件，但并非一切都完美无缺。我们看到了许多故障。有时是你写的软件出了问题，有时是系统的其他部分出了问题。但从公众的角度来看，就是“电脑坏了”，仅此而已。我拍下了这些照片，并将它们包含在我的演讲和研讨会中。
Sometimes just to make a point, guess what? Software runs the planet. Here's the thing that doesn't work. Sometimes, you know, one of my favorite ones from about 15, 20 years ago was a screenshot. I took a PowerPoint crashing. And one of the things is a dialog box saying, oh, yeah, you called basically memory error in the particular DLL and pure virtual function called. And I said, what can I learn from this? I said, here is an application that offers you. We were talking about illusions. The whole point about software is that is the business of software.
有时只是为了说明一个观点：你猜怎么着？软件运行着整个星球，但这里有个东西坏了。我最喜欢的例子之一是大约 15、20 年前的一张截图。我拍下了 PowerPoint 崩溃的画面。其中一个对话框显示：内存错误，特定的 DLL 和纯虚函数调用。我说，我能从中了解到什么？我说，这是一个为你提供服务的应用程序。我们之前谈到了幻觉，软件的全部意义就在于它是关于幻觉的生意。
It's creating an illusion. Okay. Whatever you're doing, you're creating an illusion. And for as long as anything works, that illusion is maintained. The minute something breaks, there's a crack. And you start to see how the thing was built, how it was constructed. It's like a magic trick going wrong. It's like a stage set falling apart.
它在创造一种幻觉。只要一切正常，这种幻觉就能维持。一旦有什么东西坏了，就会出现裂痕。你开始看到事物是如何构建的，它是如何被建造出来的。这就像一个出错的魔术，或者一个正在坍塌的舞台布景。
You go, oh, that's how they do that. Oh, okay, I can see behind the scenes. And so here was PowerPoint. Okay, sure, I knew Microsoft used C++, but suddenly I'm getting information about their DLLs. In fact, if I remember correctly, it was an Internet Explorer DLL that was failing. And I thought, here I am in PowerPoint,
你会说：“哦，原来他们是这样做的。哦，好吧，我能看到幕后了。”所以这就是 PowerPoint。好吧，我当然知道微软使用 C++，但突然间我得到了关于他们 DLL 的信息。事实上，如果我没记错的话，是一个 Internet Explorer 的 DLL 导致了故障。我想，我明明是在用 PowerPoint，
but an Internet Explorer DLL failing is causing PowerPoint to crash. That's interesting. And it's written in C++ and there's a pure virtual function call. Now, how can you call a pure virtual function? Well, there's a couple of cases where that might happen. Perhaps there's a path in the code
但一个 Internet Explorer 的 DLL 故障却导致了 PowerPoint 崩溃。这很有趣。它是用 C++ 编写的，并且有一个纯虚函数调用。那么，你怎么会调用一个纯虚函数呢？嗯，有几种情况可能会发生。也许代码中有一条路径
that actually leads to calling a pure virtual function. Somebody mistakenly called a pure virtual function in a constructor or destructor of the class in which it was declared. That happens every now and then. It's statically detectable. So perhaps Microsoft are not using static analysis on this or code reviews. Or alternatively, it's a memory trampling thing. Something got zeroed. And so therefore, we've got a use after free issue you know in other words i'm speculating i don't have the answer but i'm already learning something about the way the system was constructed by the way that it is failing and you can see this in a number of
实际上导致了对纯虚函数的调用。有人错误地在类的构造函数或析构函数中调用了纯虚函数，这种情况时有发生。这是静态可检测的。所以也许微软没有在这些代码上使用静态分析或代码审查。或者，这是一种内存踩踏问题。某些东西被清零了，因此我们遇到了“释放后使用”的问题。换句话说，我是在推测，我没有答案，但我已经通过它失败的方式了解了一些关于系统构建方式的信息。你可以在许多
public screens so i would use these kind of instructions kind of humorously and sometimes people would then send me examples photos they had taken you know hey look at my printer you know here's the device you know Here's the device driver version on my printer, this kind of stuff, because my printer's crashed and they got all this information. And then we hit the era of social media. And people don't start emailing me, they are atting me, they are including me. And then I start basically resharing it. And that's particularly visible on Twitter. I started resharing these screens because I thought this is kind of interesting. I think it's amusing, but it's also educational.
公共屏幕上看到这一点。所以我有时会幽默地使用这些截图，有时人们会发给我他们拍的照片，比如“嘿，看看我的打印机，这是我的设备驱动程序版本”，因为他们的打印机崩溃了，他们得到了所有这些信息。然后我们进入了社交媒体时代。人们不再给我发邮件，而是开始 @ 我，把我包含在内。然后我开始转发这些内容，这在 Twitter 上尤为明显。我开始转发这些屏幕截图，因为我觉得这很有趣，既好玩又具有教育意义。
But it's also humbling. You know, if we're software developers, we kind of make the world go round. And so, therefore, our software is in everybody's face in one way or another. Whatever level you are in the stack, there's an error message for you. And then people started calling. It was around 2016. Somebody started calling it, oh, I saw a Kevlin Henney screen at the airport. And that kind of that moniker stuck.
但这也让人感到谦卑。你知道，如果我们是软件开发人员，我们某种程度上推动了世界运转。因此，我们的软件以各种方式出现在每个人的面前。无论你在技术栈的哪个层面，总有一条错误消息在等着你。然后人们开始称呼它。大约在 2016 年，有人开始说：“哦，我在机场看到了一个 Kevlin Henney 屏幕。”这个绰号就这么传开了。
And so, yeah, it's kind of ended up being a thing. And, yeah, I've actually, you was uh it has got to that point that my you know my wife started a new job last year and it's just like oh yeah what's your you know what's your husband known for or what is it and she said oh well he's got he's got you know failure screens are named after him in some circles it's just like oh okay yeah that's kind of different but yeah that is actually the way that works and that is it is kind of interesting that that's become uh popular but i think it is you know i don't mind i don't mind that association with my name um uh it's normally normally it's a case of it's really
所以，是的，它最终成了一件事。我妻子去年开始了一份新工作，有人问她：“你丈夫因什么出名？”她说：“哦，在某些圈子里，失败屏幕是以他的名字命名的。”这确实有点不同，但这就是它的运作方式。这种现象变得流行起来确实很有趣，但我并不介意我的名字与此产生关联。通常情况下，这通常只是
just software developers and a few people who know software developers yeah but also it's kind of an interesting thing that idea that failure screens are a thing they uh we can learn from them i also like to think of it as a public service you know i i the ones that i'm going to say are a public service is when people are at um you know uh train stations and stuff like that um sometimes they will add in the rail company the relevant rail company yeah yeah and and normally they will respond oh we're really sorry about this. Which station was this? We could try and get this fixed.
软件开发人员和少数了解软件开发人员的人才知道。但“失败屏幕”是一个客观存在的事物，我们可以从中学习，这也是一件有趣的事情。我也喜欢把它看作一种公共服务。我会说这是公共服务的情况是，当人们在火车站等地遇到这种情况时，他们有时会 @ 铁路公司。通常他们会回应：“哦，我们对此深感抱歉。这是哪个车站？我们会尝试修复它。”
It's kind of like, yep, just happy to help, happy to be associated with this and to have people report it. And so my sort of succinct definition of what a Kevlin Henney screen is, is specifically it's a containment failure. It's not only a failure screen, but it's a failure screen that exposes a diagnostic that was intended for consumption by programmers or the people who designed the system, not by humans. When I was checking into the Hilton Hotel at the St. Louis committee meeting, Hilton was experiencing like a worldwide outage with their entire check-in system. And all of the hotels had to just – it was just the honor system.
这就像是，很高兴能提供帮助，很高兴能与此相关联，并让人们报告这些问题。我对“Kevlin Henney 屏幕”的简洁定义是：它具体是一种“容器故障”。它不仅是一个失败屏幕，而且是一个暴露了本应由程序员或系统设计者查看，而非普通用户查看的诊断信息的屏幕。当我在圣路易斯委员会会议期间入住希尔顿酒店时，希尔顿的整个入住系统发生了全球性故障。所有的酒店都不得不采用“诚信系统”。
They were just like, oh, what were your check-in dates? Like, you know, we'll just figure it out when the system goes back up. But I got this error on the app, which is a little hard to see here, but I'll read it out where it said like, minus 7000 colon RCI check-in failed open DB equals minus 7000 application and database versions are out of sync. So that is a Kevlin Henney in my book. But if it had simply said, we're sorry, we're experiencing a system, you know, error, we can't check you in my book. But if it had simply said, we're sorry, we're experiencing a system error, we can't check you in right now. That I don't think I would call a Kevlin Henney because that is, I think, the proper way for an error to be surfaced. And in particular,
他们只是问：“你们的入住日期是什么时候？等系统恢复后我们再处理。”但我收到了应用程序上的这个错误，虽然在这里很难看清，但我读一下：显示“负 7000，冒号，RCI 入住失败，打开数据库等于负 7000，应用程序和数据库版本不同步”。在我看来，这就是一个 Kevlin Henney。但如果它只是说“抱歉，我们遇到了系统错误，现在无法为您办理入住”，那我就不会称之为 Kevlin Henney，因为我认为这才是错误呈现的正确方式。特别是，
if I see an error message like this, where it tells me application and database versions are out of sync, what I'm getting from that is that this has failed in some way that has not been predicted by the people who developed this system. And also, if I'm seeing this error, it's likely that it's not been reported back to whoever runs that system. Because if it was, they would probably log it and send it back to them and then just tell me like we're so sorry this failed but um it's it's like it's some some edge case where the the unexpected has happened it's that idea it was in some way unexpected and and i'd agree with you because it's what you're learning is typically for from my perspective the ones that i regardless of how other people might use it i regard that i definitely regard that as a Ketlin Henny in the sense that that's for me is of interest because it reveals something about the way the system was built in a way that was clearly not intended. It's not part of the illusion.
如果我看到像这样告诉我“应用程序和数据库版本不同步”的错误消息，我从中得到的信息是，系统以一种开发人员未曾预料到的方式失败了。而且，如果我看到了这个错误，很可能它还没有被报告给系统运维人员。因为如果报告了，他们可能会记录下来并反馈，然后只是告诉我“很抱歉失败了”。这就像是某种边缘情况，发生了意想不到的事情。我同意你的观点，因为从我的角度来看，无论别人怎么使用这个词，我绝对认为这就是一个 Kevlin Henney，因为它揭示了系统构建方式中显然非预期的部分。它不是幻觉的一部分。
If something says, I'm sorry, we're experiencing problems right now. That's just, and I'm sorry, this was anticipated. It was planned for. This is actually business as usual in that sense because it was anticipated but if in failing it surprises both the both the reader and a developer you know if you said this to the developer it's just oh that's surprising we weren't expecting that you know it surprises everybody and it shows us something about what was assumed and what was about how something was built yeah and this can be integer overflow errors um you know every now and then you get a piece of software that sort of says that gives you um you know maximum the
如果屏幕显示“抱歉，我们目前遇到问题”，那是预料之中的，是计划内的。从某种意义上说，这是正常的业务流程。但如果失败让读者和开发人员都感到惊讶——如果你告诉开发人员，他们会说“哦，这很令人惊讶，我们没预料到”——它就让所有人感到意外，并向我们展示了关于假设和构建方式的信息。是的，这可能是整数溢出错误，你偶尔会得到一段软件，它给你显示一个 32 位数字的最大值，
max for a 32-bit number and you sort of suddenly well yeah that probably shouldn't be in the screen um uh and you suddenly see various bits and pieces and one of the most common ones people experience is nan um in web pages you know that was a popular one um you know i got a few of those we just had a general election in this country and uh there was a point where i think it was a bbc's coverage um they were talking about various percentages because that's what you do on election night and apparently um, you know, Nan out of Nan seats have been won by. It's just like, OK, the parliamentary swing is Nan. OK, well, that's probably not what you wanted to say.
你会突然觉得“嗯，这可能不应该出现在屏幕上”。你会突然看到各种零碎的信息。人们最常遇到的一种是网页上的“NaN”。那是一个很流行的例子。我们国家刚刚举行了大选，在 BBC 的报道中，他们谈论各种百分比，因为选举之夜就是这样。显然，“NaN 个席位中的 NaN 个席位已被赢得”。就像是，“好吧，议会摇摆度是 NaN。好吧，这可能不是你想表达的意思。”
And that kind of thing is the thing that is surprising. It shows that something was not anticipated. It shows you that something is broken in a way that surprises all people concerned. But it also reveals how the thing was built. It reveals something internal. The diagnostics that I like best from user-facing things are sort of a happy middle ground between the two. And I think Hulu and the Microsoft blue screen of death perhaps do this best so when in hulu if there's some sort of error um hulu will usually say like we're sorry there was an error like you know uh
这种事情是令人惊讶的。它表明有些事情没有被预料到，它表明有些东西以一种让所有相关人员都感到惊讶的方式坏掉了。但它也揭示了事物是如何构建的，揭示了内部结构。我最喜欢的面向用户的诊断信息是两者之间的幸福平衡点。我认为 Hulu 和微软的“蓝屏死机”可能做得最好。在 Hulu 中，如果出现某种错误，
we couldn't play this video um you know please refer and it'll give you like instructions like please try logging out or something but it also has an error code, a code that says, and it's not an error code that tells you, the user, anything. That's not necessarily what I'm looking for. If I get an app that just tells me, we're sorry, we're experiencing a system error, and then I go to report that to the people who created the app, because maybe the issue is on my end. Maybe it's something that hasn't been reported yet. If I want to be helpful and report it, if all I have is, sorry, it's a system error, I can send a screenshot.
Hulu 通常会说“抱歉，出现了一个错误，我们无法播放此视频，请参考……”，并给出一些说明，比如“请尝试注销”之类的。但它也有一个错误代码。这个错误代码并不告诉用户任何信息，这不一定是我想要的。如果我得到的应用程序只是告诉我“抱歉，我们遇到了系统错误”，然后我去向创建该应用程序的人报告，因为也许问题出在我这边，也许这是一个尚未被报告的问题。如果我想提供帮助并报告它，如果我只有“抱歉，这是一个系统错误”，我可以发送截图。
But that doesn't necessarily have the information they need. But if it's something like a Hulu error where they've got some code, one, I can give them the code. And two, I can Google the code. And in some cases, like, I do learn some information about that because maybe some people online have figured out like what these codes mean um and i and i think that that's like the best model for things that have um yeah uh like a user-facing interfaces like like mask don't don't expose programmer stuff up to civilians but have some reference code or something so that if somebody reports it, you can get the useful information out of it. Yeah, it offers something distinct, but it shows both.
但这不一定包含他们需要的信息。但如果是像 Hulu 那样的错误，他们有一个代码，我可以给他们代码，我也可以在谷歌上搜索这个代码。在某些情况下，我确实能学到一些信息，因为也许网上有些人已经弄清楚了这些代码的含义。我认为这是面向用户界面的最佳模式：不要把程序员的东西暴露给普通用户，但要有一些参考代码，这样如果有人报告，你就能从中提取有用的信息。是的，它提供了一些独特的东西，但两者兼顾。
Yeah, something's gone wrong, but basically it shows a kind of a deliberate approach. There's an intent here. We have designed for this. We have accounted for the things that cannot be accounted for it's part of our architecture i think a lot of developers regard that as either not that you know sometimes it falls between the posts sometimes you have an organization where you know ui designers yeah ui designers kept separate you know work differently separately from developers and the ui designs go our user experience is all about this that's errors is not part of the user
是的，出了问题，但它基本上展示了一种深思熟虑的方法。这里有某种意图。我们为此进行了设计。我们考虑了那些无法被考虑到的事情，这是我们架构的一部分。我认为很多开发人员认为这要么不是……有时它处于两难境地。有时你所在的组织中，UI 设计师与开发人员是分开工作的，UI 设计师说“我们的用户体验是关于这个的，错误不是我们关心的用户体验的一部分，
experience that we care about because that's not shiny and interesting. But actually errors is part of the user experience. And then developers are sitting there going, well, that's kind of error stuff. That's not really what I'm here to do. And maybe it fails in a way they're thinking from a programmer point of view,
因为那不光鲜亮丽”。但实际上，错误是用户体验的一部分。而开发人员坐在那里说“嗯，那是错误处理的事，那不是我来这里要做的”。也许它以他们从程序员角度思考的方式失败了，
but not from a user perspective. So it falls between these two posts and you often end up with either something you know something's inadequate either way either you end up sort of anticipating but not offering useful feedback or information somebody can do something with in other words you just say we're sorry there is a problem well that's astoundingly vague um i hate those ones where you know like you sometimes you get it's just like an error has occurred so yes but how exactly do i can't google for this and i also can't report it meaningfully um i've i can't give them the thing that they would give me you know here here is the little
但从用户角度来看却不是。所以它落在了这两个立场之间，你最终得到的往往是不充分的。要么你预料到了但没有提供有用的反馈或信息，要么你只是说“抱歉，出了问题”。这太模糊了。我讨厌那些只显示“发生了一个错误”的提示。是的，但具体怎么回事？我无法谷歌搜索，也无法有意义地报告它。我无法给他们他们需要的东西，
treasure item that you can give us and we will unlock this you know it's just like this is the key for us they don't give me that information. I can't do anything with it. There is an error is not false, but it's so vague that the truth is not useful. And then at the other end of the scale is like, here's your stack choice. You know, here's this arbitrary message. And that is kind of like, what does that mean to me as a user? You know, I can't do anything with that either. But it also shows me you didn't care or hadn't really thought that failure was an option.
那个可以解锁问题的“宝藏”。他们没有给我那个信息，我对此无能为力。“有一个错误”并非不真实，但它太模糊了，以至于真相毫无用处。而在另一个极端，是“这是你的堆栈跟踪”。这对我这个用户来说意味着什么？我也无法对此做任何事情。但这同时也向我表明，你并不关心，或者根本没想过失败是一种可能。
And this whole topic also is applicable at the level of libraries and our interactions with other programmers and how our libraries report errors. I used to, sort of my career, I worked on HPX, which was a distributed system. And we had this distributed exception mechanism where if something failed in another node, that exception would get propagated. And eventually, asynchronously, you would receive the failure as the system got shut down. And even within a single node, if you had something that failed in another thread,
整个话题也适用于库的层面，以及我们与其他程序员的互动，以及我们的库如何报告错误。我职业生涯中曾从事 HPX 的工作，这是一个分布式系统。我们有一个分布式异常机制，如果另一个节点出现故障，该异常会被传播。最终，当系统关闭时，你会异步收到故障通知。即使在单个节点内，如果另一个线程出现故障，
then it would be reported as an exception while the other threads shut down. And one problem we would have is people would send us error reports where they would just be like, I got this exception. I don't know what it means. I don't know where it came from.
它也会在其他线程关闭时作为异常报告。我们遇到的一个问题是，人们发给我们的错误报告只是说：“我收到了这个异常，我不知道它意味着什么，我不知道它来自哪里。”
And it would be very hard for them to, on their own, get a stack trace and a debugger. Because the asynchronous event that caused the failure has already occurred and is gone. And this is just the reporting of that thing. And so, we built in to our exception catching throwing mechanism, something that would take a stack trace. And we also would take a stack trace. And we also would capture the environment variables. And one of the reasons we did that is distributed system. We would want to know, like, hmm, what's the
他们很难自己获取堆栈跟踪和调试器。因为导致故障的异步事件已经发生并消失了。这只是该事件的报告。因此，我们在异常捕获和抛出机制中内置了一些东西，可以获取堆栈跟踪。我们还会捕获环境变量。我们这样做的一个原因是分布式系统，我们想知道“嗯，这个发生故障的节点的具体设置是什么？”你实际上看到许多编程语言和许多库默认会打印出堆栈跟踪，比如 Python。
specific setup of this node where the thing failed? And you see actually a lot of programming languages and a lot of libraries have a stack trace that'll print out by default and their error reporting like python does this um uh and like i i seg faulted the python interpreter doing some
我前几天在做一些疯狂的事情时让 Python 解释器段错误了，但我没有得到堆栈跟踪。我当时想：“我现在该怎么办？我没有堆栈跟踪，我也不知道如何以我想要的方式在 Python 解释器上运行 GDB。”LLVM 也是如此。许多编译器会转储编译器内部的堆栈跟踪。有些编译器甚至会说：“嘿，我们已经把你需要提交错误报告的所有信息放在了 /tmp 目录下的一个文件中，去复制这个文件然后作为错误报告发送。”
wild stuff the other day and i didn't get a stack trace and i was like like what do i do now like i don't have i don't have a stack trace i don't and i don't know how to go about getting GDB running on the Python interpreter in the way I want. And LLVM does this as well. A lot of compilers will dump out a stack trace of the compiler internals. And some compilers will even say, hey, we've put into a file in slash temp, we've put all the information that you need to file a bug report just like go copy this file and then like send it as a bug report um and uh i i think that like if you're developing a system uh anything that's going to play at scale you really want to build in some some you want to think about this like how are people going to report bugs to you
我认为，如果你正在开发一个系统，任何要在规模化环境下运行的东西，你真的需要内置一些东西，你需要考虑这一点：人们将如何向你报告错误？
uh because otherwise you're going to get you're going to get people opening issues which is just like i i got you know file not found exception what does that mean yeah and um yeah you're going to end up with a lot of noise i mean that's that's the thing is either you end up with information that's not useful because it's not really information or you end up with just like a load of noise and you've got to cut through that to try and find something. And I think that that, again, it goes back to this kind of issue of constraints and how sometimes the shape of development changes over time. You will, you know, there will be failures. They will need to be reported. How are you going to deal with
否则，你最终会得到人们提交的问题，比如“我收到了文件未找到异常，那是什么意思？”你会得到很多噪音。这就是问题所在：要么你得到的信息毫无用处，要么你最终得到一堆噪音，你必须从中筛选出有用的东西。我认为这又回到了约束的问题，以及开发形态如何随时间变化。总会有故障发生，它们需要被报告。你打算如何处理
that? And that is something that historically people have always said, going back to, I just highlighted it as the UX people versus the developers before. But actually, I'm going to say it's all wrong. So let's take a step further back. It's just like, this is in the architecture. Sometimes a developer will say, oh, I'm going to solve it like this. And they're thinking of it as a programming problem. It's actually not a pro it's architectural. It's, it's about the, what's the user experience. What about the customer relations? So it's even the customer experience at that level. And so although a developer sometimes sees, you know, you're close to the code and though, so you see it as a localized problem. Oh, a thing might bad might happen. Oh, I'll just, you know, either we report this or I just log it or something simple or I throw an exception or I just rely on the magic of undefined behavior to figure out whatever this platform is going to do.
这一点？这是历史上人们一直在说的，回到我之前强调的 UX 人员与开发人员的对比。但实际上，我要说这完全错了。让我们退后一步。这就在架构中。有时开发人员会说“哦，我要这样解决它”，他们把它当作一个编程问题。实际上它不是，它是架构性的。它是关于用户体验是什么，客户关系是什么。所以它甚至在那个层面上是客户体验。虽然开发人员有时会因为离代码很近而将其视为局部问题——“哦，可能会发生坏事，哦，我只是报告一下，或者我记录一下，或者做点简单的处理，或者抛出一个异常，或者依靠未定义行为的魔力来决定这个平台会做什么。”
And maybe that is going to be a segfault with a core dump or maybe it's going to be a windows exception or whatever and somebody else or you know somebody else's problem again douglas adams somebody having having an sep field around something it's somebody else's problem makes it invisible and each group thinks that the architect says oh that's just error handling that's a programmer problem uh the user user experience person goes like well you know what this isn't really what this is about even the product owner is going to start saying oh well that's not really what we're in this for. That's not the value of this product. So it's kind of everybody's problem, which is why sometimes it ends up being nobody's problem, but it becomes much more visible. We see these failures. They are frustrating, but how do people act on them? How enabled do they feel? And then going back to where you say, if I've got a searchable term, then maybe I find something online.
也许那会是一个带有核心转储的段错误，或者是一个 Windows 异常，或者又是道格拉斯·亚当斯所说的“别人有问题”（SEP 场），让它变得不可见。每个群体都认为架构师会说“哦，那只是错误处理，那是程序员的问题”。用户体验人员会说“嗯，你知道吗，这并不是重点”。甚至产品负责人也会开始说“哦，那不是我们做这个的目的，那不是这个产品的价值”。所以这成了每个人的问题，这就是为什么有时它最终成了没人的问题，但它变得更加明显。我们看到了这些故障。它们令人沮丧，但人们如何应对它们？他们感到有多大的能力？回到你说的，如果我有一个可搜索的术语，那么也许我能在网上找到一些东西。
And as a user, I can understand, oh, okay, other people have this. It's not just me. Or this is how I report it. Or they've thought out a process. Just send us this file and that's fine, you know, for the more developer-centric thing. But what you're doing is you're actually enabling people to say, oh, okay, you know, you're not ignoring me. It's nothing worse. It failed and you're on your own, kid. Oh, wow. You know, you're not ignoring me. It's nothing worse. It failed and
作为用户，我可以理解“哦，好吧，其他人也有这个问题，不仅仅是我”。或者这是我报告它的方式。或者他们已经想出了一个流程。只需把这个文件发给我们，对于更以开发人员为中心的事情来说，这就很好。但你实际上是在让人们说“哦，好吧，你没有忽视我”。没有什么比“它失败了，而你只能自求多福”更糟糕的了。
you're on your own kid. Oh, wow. You're stuck in the rain. It's dark. It's miserable. And you can't get your work done because whatever has failed. Here, you're at least offering people like, okay, you've had a problem, but don't worry, we've got this. You know, there's a thing that you can do. And, you know, we apologize for that and so on. And that's not something that happens by an individual developer having an afterthought. It's very much kind of a whole team and a whole architecture view rather than a bolt-on and a detail. Yeah, you have to design for failure and you have to design for, for debugging. Um, and, and, you know, if you do that, like, I think, I think the languages that, that stack trace by default on error, um, it's far, like,
你被困在雨中，天黑了，很痛苦，因为某些东西坏了，你无法完成工作。在这里，你至少向人们提供了一种选择：“好吧，你遇到了问题，但别担心，我们有办法。”你可以做某事，我们对此表示歉意等等。这不是单个开发人员事后想到的，这非常像是一个团队和整个架构的视角，而不是一个附加的细节。是的，你必须为失败而设计，你必须为调试而设计。如果你这样做，我认为那些默认在错误时堆栈跟踪的语言，
it's far simpler for me to fix a problem because I'm going to say 70, 80% of the time, just from the stack trace, uh, just knowing like where in the code, which function did the bad thing happen from, is enough for me to know. And in C++, I don't get that by default. And if I open up the debugger in C++, I, by default, don't compile my code
对我来说修复问题要简单得多。因为我会说 70% 到 80% 的情况下，仅凭堆栈跟踪，知道代码中哪个函数出了问题，就足以让我知道了。而在 C++ 中，我默认得不到这些。如果我打开 C++ 调试器，我默认不会编译我的代码
with debugging information on it. I compile it with O3. And I have a lot of problems that only show up at O3. And by default, I open up the debugger and it doesn't give me the stack trace. I don't have a way to get that stack trace and figure out exactly where I am. I was thinking just, you were talking about Hilton Honors
并带有调试信息。我用 O3 编译它，而我有很多问题只在 O3 下出现。默认情况下，我打开调试器，它不给我堆栈跟踪。我没有办法获取那个堆栈跟踪并弄清楚我到底在哪里。我刚才在想，你谈到了希尔顿荣誉客会，
and I've got a screenshot from a website. I can't remember what I was doing, but it was Hilton. And it's a Hilton Honors one. And it gives me this perfect stack trace it's hilton on as well and it gives me this perfect stack trace it's a java stack trace and you can go through it you can tell everything about the technology stack that they're using um which curiously enough leads us straight back into the discussion of security because you can kind of look at this it's like a manifest of like oh you're building it like that oh okay you know it's just like um and if you and if you have
我有一个来自网站的截图。我不记得我在做什么，但那是希尔顿。它是希尔顿荣誉客会的一个页面，它给了我这个完美的堆栈跟踪。它是一个 Java 堆栈跟踪，你可以浏览它，你可以看出他们使用的所有技术栈。奇怪的是，这直接把我们带回了安全讨论，因为你可以查看它，它就像一个清单：“哦，你是这样构建的，哦，好吧。”
any kind of like guesses like oh, oh, okay, you're using this version, which I happen to know has a vulnerability, then you could, you know, if you're a bad actor, then you can get in on that. Oh, yes. Seeing like language or stack version information in like a, you know, a publicly exposed error from anything that's on the internet is like a little bit scary. It says something about the security posture of the system. I wonder how many vulnerabilities have grown out of information that's been found from a Kevlin Henney screen.
如果你有任何猜测，比如“哦，你正在使用这个版本，我碰巧知道它有一个漏洞”，那么如果你是一个坏人，你就可以利用它。哦，是的。在互联网上公开暴露的错误中看到语言或堆栈版本信息有点可怕。它说明了系统的安全态势。我想知道有多少漏洞是源于从 Kevlin Henney 屏幕中发现的信息。
Oh, that's a really interesting thought, isn't it? Actually. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Because sometimes you don't even need to know anything about the stack. It's just like, screen oh that's a really interesting thought isn't it actually yeah yeah yeah because sometimes you don't even need to know anything about the stack it's just like if you get enough information about what type of error has occurred like and you can re-trigger the error again then you might you might be able to figure out how to use that to do something something of evil yeah yeah something malicious oh i like that i mean i don't of course i don't know but no no i'm not i'm not on record for saying that damn let's let's no but yeah that's the point that it is and again you are you're you by showing the fracture lines you know in in this broken illusion uh it allows somebody
哦，那真是一个非常有趣的想法，不是吗？实际上。是的。因为有时你甚至不需要知道关于堆栈的任何信息。如果关于发生了什么类型的错误的信息足够多，并且你可以再次触发该错误，那么你也许就能弄清楚如何利用它来做一些邪恶的事情。是的，一些恶意的行为。哦，我喜欢这个。我的意思是，我当然不知道，但我没有记录在案说那个。不，但这就是重点。通过展示这些断裂线，在这个破碎的幻觉中，
else to potentially it's it's interesting from an academic perspective is interesting from a support perspective but for somebody who is a bad actor, it's kind of like, OK, I know something here that I can take advantage of. And that's the caution that needs to be done. And again, it reveals, again, why this is an architectural question. It's got to be able to say, this is how we fail. This is how we fail gracefully, but with sufficient, you know, with sufficient grace and sufficient information, but without showing the whole, you know, without dropping our whole hand on the table and saying, here's what I'm playing. You've got, you know, there's got to be this balance, but it has to be intentional. It doesn't happen by accident. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP, the podcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's's episode as well as a link to a get up discussion where you can leave thoughts comments and questions thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day
它允许其他人潜在地利用它。从学术角度来看这很有趣，从支持角度来看这很有趣，但对于一个坏人来说，这就像是“OK，我知道这里有一些我可以利用的东西”。这就是需要谨慎的地方。它再次揭示了为什么这是一个架构问题。它必须能够说：“这就是我们失败的方式。这就是我们优雅失败的方式，带有足够的信息，但不会把整副牌都摊在桌面上说‘这就是我正在玩的’。”你必须有这种平衡，但这必须是有意的。它不是偶然发生的。请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用程序中，还是在 ADSPthepodcast.com 上，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听，希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。
low quality high quantity that is the tagline of our podcast it's not the tagline our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
低质量、高数量，这就是我们播客的口号。这不是口号，我们的口号是“带有信息碎片的混乱”。此剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。